determina el área y perímetro del
polígono bueno vamos a empezar con el
área que le voy a poner el área ok esta
área está partida en dos partes aquí
abajo hay una parte rectangular que voy
a pintar en color verde en color verde
esta de aquí es un área rectangular y
esa es muy sencilla de calcular
simplemente hay que multiplicar base que
es 8 por altura que es 4 entonces esa
área es igual a 8 por 4 y luego tenemos
esta área de aquí arriba que es un área
triangular para encontrar el área de un
triángulo basta multiplicar su base por
su altura y dividir eso entre 2 déjame
déjame ponerle aquí otro rectángulo para
acordarnos de dónde sale esa fórmula si
multiplicamos base por altura nada más
obtendríamos el área de todo este
rectángulo verdad base por altura se le
sería el área de todo el rectángulo pero
queremos el triángulo que sólo ocupa la
mitad porque este triángulo es el mismo
que es eso lo que girado bueno entonces
regresando al problema aquí la base
sería 8 centímetros porque esto es un
rectángulo la altura sería 3 centímetros
y x
el área del triángulo que es esta área
roja de acá sería igual a base por
altura entre 2 entonces aquí hay que
sumar más 8 por 3 dividido dividido
entre el 2 y aquí ya podemos hacer la
cuenta esto de aquí es igual es igual 4
por 8 es 32 es igual a 32 más 8 entre 12
4 por 3 es 12 32 más 12 que es igual a
44 44 centímetros cuadrados vale
centímetros cuadrados aquí había
centímetros aquí había centímetros
centímetros por centímetros son
centímetros cuadrados muy bien entonces
eso de ahí es el área ahora pasemos al
perímetro que voy a pintar con este
color morado entonces perímetro le voy a
poner p nada más para encontrar el
perímetro lo que tenemos que hacer es
sumar las longitudes de todos los lados
es la longitud de cerca que
necesitaríamos para rodear toda esta
figura vale entonces el perímetro
simplemente se obtiene sumando este 5
con este 5 de acá 5
con este 4 4 con el 8 de aquí más 8 más
y este 4 de acá más 4 entonces el
perímetro de 5 548 4 y eso es igual a 5
5 es 10 más 4 es 14 14 8 es 22 y 22 más
4 es igual a 26 26 y ya está bueno es
importante ponerle aquí centímetros de
símbolos es importante ponerle las
unidades y tiene sentido que aquí sea
centímetros porque el perímetro es algo
que nada más necesita una dimensión
verdad simplemente nos dice pues cuánta
longitud necesitamos y aquí arriba
teníamos centímetros cuadrados porque el
área es una magnitud de 2 dimensiones
vale entonces el área del polígono es 44
centímetros cuadrados y su perímetro es
26 centímetros